foreign
councilor John Ward leader of baby
District Council and I'll be chairing
this meeting
may I remind you some domestic
arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave please
ensure your mobile phones are on silent
or Switched Off
finally we'll be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern.gov so please
commend us make sure they are logged in
and ready to use the app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except whether our confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed by
entering this meeting as a speaker you
are also consenting to being recorded by
the council and to the possible use of
those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press and record film photograph
will broadcast this meeting when the
public and the Press are not lawfully
excluded
I'd now like to move to the agenda
please so item one apologies for absence
thank you chair we have
councilor Gould and councilor mccrawal
thank you item two to receive
Declarations of pecunery either
registerable or non-registerable
interest by members are there any to
declare
nope
thank you item three paper BCA 2243 to
confirm the minutes of the meeting held
on the 6th of February 2023
so I'll go through the minutes
if there are any points of accuracy
please let me know so page five anyone
uh I have one
uh typo mistake on page five and that is
right at the bottom on on the
penultimate line it should say confirmed
rather than conformed
page six anyone
again I have one typo on page six again
the penultimate line it should say
assets not assists
page seven
page eight
page nine
page 10.
page 11.
and finally page 12.
so if there are no um further comments
about the minutes may have a proposal
please
cassarathi thank you and a second
councilor Busby thank you
so we'll now conduct the vote
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
that is six votes full that's unanimous
thank you
item five to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme none received
item five questions by councilors
item six matters referred by the
overview of scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees
overview and security committee or the
joint order than standards committee
thank you
item seven forthcoming decisions list
members of the cabinet are there any
comments on the forthcoming decisions of
this
nope
okay then
moving on item eight paper BCA 2244 the
general fund Financial monitoring for
2022-23 quarter three I'd like to invite
the cabinet member for finance assets
and Investments to introduce the report
Council Busby
thank you chair
I'm not going to go through this in
great detail in fact I'm not going to go
through it in any detail I think we've
all had a good look at this it's a very
thorough paper all I'll do is if you
could turn to page 21
which shows the
the current forecast variances
I think it's useful just to look at how
those variances have changed since
Quarter Two
there's not been a significant amount of
change
um
on corporate resources there's a bit
there's a difference of about 80 000
where we've reduced the forecast for
interim staff costs
um customer operations again about 50
000 pounds underspend for staff
vacancies
these are the differences between the
two quarters
uh
housing there's 135 000 pounds increase
in income from Grants and rents in the
forecast
postage costs and spend for mate for the
May elections
eighty thousand worse
so the net service expenditure is
showing uh 185 000 pounds
better position than we were looking at
in Quarter Two
apart from that there's not been a great
deal the interest payable there's ninety
thousand increase in in the borrowing
rates and
um
that's just about it really so if
anybody's got any questions
other than that I'd like to propose that
we note the this report
thank you
thank you councilor Busby
um may I have a second for this
questions do any members of the cabinet
have any questions for Council Busby on
their support
uh councilor Hinton do you have any
questions
nope
well we'll move over into debate then
would anyone like to open up the debate
on this
any comments from anyone we're all happy
with it casserati
actually a question and I'm just trying
to find it in the um
paperwork which I haven't yet but um
it's to do with I think it's the gas
um charge for
for the Leisure centers which I'm
guessing is kingfisher Leisure Pool and
there's a bit in here about how it was
in budget and then its recharged and
then it features again and then is
recharged or something I just wondered
if when I looked at the figures I
thought they're not actually the same
figures so I just wondered if somebody
could explain how that works
okay
thank you I think it'll pass that
straight to either
throw Rebecca
I'll look for the page as well
uh referring to I'm trying to read the
page number 22 I think
um where we've got the Leisure contracts
at the bottom so what happens is we
actually pay for the gas and then we
reach out everyone out sorry Abby Croft
then pay us for the gas charges so you
can see this operating costs and then
there's the income as well
um there's a 16k under spend but that's
due to rates relief so that's kind of
separate to the the gas coming
but it's expenditure and then a recharge
coming in from abbeycroft
Melissa is absolutely right that is
where I saw it
um so the other bit I don't quite
understand is that if there's a recharge
in there how does that work when I
presume the contract is actually with
abbeycroft direct that's what it appears
to say
[Music]
hello thanks for the question so
um I'm looking at it in a in a bit more
detail from some of our working papers
what has happened was when the original
budget was set it was set with the gas
cost and a recharge but in actuality
um Abby Croft
pays for the gas directly so
um so we're not actually incurring that
gas expenditure which is why there's a
59 000 under spend on the operating cost
because we've not actually incurred that
expenditure but then likewise we're not
getting the recharge in either which is
why there's been a showing us an
overspend on the income line so overall
there's there's no impact on on the
budget but they're just because um the
way we were showing it in the budget
it's showing as a two separate lines
okay can I ask if it's going to be the
same in the future or will it not
feature at all because it seems to me
that if we're actually featuring
something that we then don't pay there's
very little point
for me to intervene but this this is
quite a unique situation that was that
arose as part of the solar carports
funding
so the original proposal was that we
were going to
um in fact government were requiring us
to um pay the energy bills so the person
that made the bid had to be the person
with paying the energy bills
as it transpired and we managed to
negotiate that out so I think there's
been a that there was a sort of tweak
through the process of the budget times
and because it is abacoff that now paid
them
um but that's why there's a slight
anomaly in terms of that which Rebecca's
just explained it I don't think it
happens very often that's just because
the bid we put into government for solar
carports
yeah
thank you Jim okay thank you does anyone
else have anything they they wish to say
okay I think there's just one comment
I'd like to meet and obviously the um uh
667 and we understand that the reason
for that overspend
um and the impact that's had on on the
position so far but um
I think it shows how prudent we were in
putting that half a million in the
inflationary precious Reserve because
there has meant that um
we've got that money and it's there to
do what it was intended to do which was
to mitigate the pressures that inflation
we knew was going to cause on on the
budget for this year and which has
largely contributed to that 667 so uh I
think um that that's that's the good
news that comes out of this and um we
are able to uh to cope with with that
forecast adverse there is
so if there are no further comments then
I think we can move straight to the vote
thank you chair that road is now in
progress
thank you that is six votes for that's
unanimous thank you
item nine paper BCA 2245 the HRA
Financial monitoring for 2022-23 quarter
three
I'd like to invite the cabinet member
for finance assets and Investments to
introduce this report councilor Busby
okay again the same deal here
um unfortunately there has been quite a
significant increase in the deficit ish
that we're forecasting
of about 900 000 pounds which is down to
the increased costs of Building Services
and repairs and maintenance
unfortunately so we're now looking at
a deficit in the region of 1.7 million I
think
if
anybody's got any questions
again happy to take them
thank you Castle Busby so that's
proposed by you may have a second to
please Council McLaren
does anyone have any questions Council
McLaren
thank you chair it's it's not really
well it is related to finance but it's
on on the report 11.2
have got since 2020 Weber has installed
85 airsource heat pumps in Council owned
homes and I was wondering whether we had
done some evaluation on the
effectiveness and the efficiency of
these in terms of money or benefit to
Residents thank you
thank you Council McLaren uh Council
Osborne do you want to pick that up or
should I ask
wants to know if we've got any data on
the effectiveness of the the heat pumps
and and uh any of the financial benefits
of having those I guess as opposed to
gas heating
I would have to go to the director of
Housing Council thank you okay
Deborah are you able to provide any
insight please
the moment so we haven't got any data at
the moment but we're going to um we are
working on it
thank you Deborah thank you
councilor Osborne sorry sorry
thank you Mr chairman if I can if I can
just add to that as well bearing in mind
that this is the quarter three reporting
so we've moved on a lot quite a bit
since then so that's when that work will
start when we get towards the beginning
of this new year when the work will
start commencing on the um
effectiveness of it but bearing in mind
all the other work that we're doing as
well for Building Services
um it has to take a back seat for the
moment but it will be being looked at
and monitored
yes
um it was just that it was raised within
my
residence
okay
I had to recall my understanding is that
we actually had some problems with the
heat pumps that we've put in that they
weren't worked well they were working
but they weren't as
good as we expect them to be in terms of
noise I think and things like that so I
guess we're probably still evaluating
that I think it's the kind of thing that
you put on a new house if I'm not
convinced it's necessarily a good thing
for a refit but I may be wrong
Council Oswald
yeah thank you Mr chairman I think some
of the issues are our residents trying
to adapt and get used to that new form
of heating but I think it's fair to say
we need to wait until the evaluation is
in place for us to be able to establish
whether they are as effective as we
hoping that they are
thank you
any other questions from anyone
I'll move over and ask councilor Hinton
do you have any questions on HRA
thank you Mr chairman just a quick one
really based on those the comments that
just come out about heat pumps or
something in the paper today about uh
heat pumps have to be installed within
it can't be installed within three
meters of
boundary walls and so forth and so it
implied the heat pumps are gonna have to
be installed in the bottom of people's
Gardens has this sort of been factored
into our progress as far as replacing
existing Energy Systems with the pumps
this time we can go to the director of
housing I'm not sure I don't always
believe what I read in newspapers I have
to say but I will go to the director of
housing to to answer that one thank you
it's a quality paper
Deborah are you able to yeah they're not
able to shed any light on that comment
which was in the paper at the weekends
I will um
and find out
thank you
probably something that will have to
come out via building regs or something
like that in the in the
dim and distant future a bit like
reinforcing rooms of sheds for solar
panels
okay I think this is right we're
actually approaching it in the right way
which is to have done a few and evaluate
them rather than just rushing in and
trying to do hundreds and
okay
Tom did you have something you wanted to
uh and yes just on the point of heat
pumps I believe what the article was
referring to was that heat pumps
wouldn't be allowed as permitted
development they would require planning
permission if they were within certain
parameters of adjacent buildings or
anything like that so that things could
be considered properly noise assessments
and those kind of things so it wasn't a
categoric they cannot be within X
distance of the boundary but that they
would require permission in order to be
so so it adds a layer of complication
rather than necessarily saying that it
can't happen
thank you that's very helpful thank you
okay
um
members of the cabinet are there any uh
comments you wish to make in in the
debate on on this paper
Council Osborne
I'm really looking at this one it was
only last week we approved actually the
the HRA budget so it seems a little bit
strange thinking backwards instead of
instead of forward no I think it's a
pretty comprehensive performance says it
all I'd just like to appoint members
um especially Our member for the
environment sitting right next to me on
the environmental implications and the
work that's being done alongside to put
that into place and 11.6 surveyors have
been studying for the retrofit
coordinators diploma I think that's
excellent news as well as long as all
the other stuff that goes with it so
obviously housing team are playing their
part in US delivering our Target there
for Net Zero by 2013. thank you Mr Jim
thank you Council Osborne
okay any further comments
it won't debate yes yeah
it's
it's encouraging to see that we have
moved along the green agenda with the
air source heat pumps and replacing
oil-fired storage communal heating with
individual heat bumps Etc and it's good
news to to see that people are being
trained in retrofit because that's going
to be more demanding as we as the
council moves forward
so yes but like all these new things
we're going to have to wait at least a
year before we get any data and then
it's going to take a couple of years
before we get any meaningful data so
that we actually have comparisons but
we're on the right track
thank you thank you councilman
anyone else
in which case we'll move to the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
that is six votes for that's unanimous
champ thank you
item 10 paper BCA 2246 the quarter three
performance monitoring
um this items for noting in councilor
macrae's absence I will introduce the
report
um for cabinet today
um so we have the core 3 Performance
report
um and this this current briefing
provides a selection of the performance
highlights for each of our strategic
strategic priorities and intended to
give cabinet members an opportunity to
consider our achievements for the
quarter 3 2022-23
uh the areas where performance is worth
highlighting uh complaints that the
numbers are down
web web visits
um but that there's changing numbers
there although there are encouraging
signs on social media turn around
um
I'd like to get members to note the
average number of days for standard void
relates
um
uh in terms of data quality we're we're
addressing errors in previous cabinet
reports
um and also at the end of quarter three
um in terms of our key performance
indicators we've only have usable kpis
for 21 out of our 66 outcomes so there's
more work being done on that and we plan
to reach a minimum 80 coverage for
um which is effectively coverage of 53
outcomes by the end of quarter four
um it would be useful if individuals can
pick up highlights in their own areas
I'll just kick off with the economy
performance indicators some of the key
points to note 160 attendees at the
business Innovation Awards where 22
businesses were nominated across eight
categories
with q technology being announced the
overall winner
70 stakeholders achieved for attended
four Workshop sessions to help shape our
new culture Heritage and physical
economy strategy and more on that later
when we come to debate that item
the solar carpool project was good
that is now in process of delivering
nearly a hundred and eighty uh thousand
kilowatt hours per annum and saving 62
tons of carbon parameter
Leisure centers
and that was completed under budget
which was was actually news
um in terms of other things the virtual
High Street has now exceeded 400
businesses so that's that's going strong
we've now got a marketing database of
nearly 4 000 contacts following the
visit Suffolk campaign
which is very useful digital skills for
business program completed with around
26 businesses taking part in training
and mentoring and we've got the schools
Enterprise Challenge and two schools in
baber uh involved in that one is Sudbury
and one in East burgolt
so
um in terms of other things a councilor
Gould has sent me a note
um
and she's particularly encouraged by the
monitoring success efficiency of both
the water filtration and solar carports
at the Kingfisher which we're going to
be putting in place
and that the tree planting strategy is
now underway
um and uh so that that's that's going to
be good news for our biodiversity AIMS
in the future
can I ask anyone else if they wish to
council counselor McLaren would you like
to say a few words
well as you can see from the communities
and well-being director at the very busy
three months but I'm not going to repeat
the detail there's enough detail in
there for everybody to read but there's
just some elements that I think needs a
special mention
I want to mention the locality teams
which are divided into green blue and
yellow across both districts they have
not yet been operating a full year
but the evidence of their work is
impressive
as each team has developed under the
direction of three new assistant
managers over the past few months this
report is evidence of their hard work
together as a new group in
not in the report but which needs
recognition is the hosting of the parish
liaison meeting in East Burgaw which was
a success the
divided all the Practical support needed
for that event
and we're able to display the wide
variety of services they offer which was
important to all the parish council's
present
I'm sure to have very little money in
their directorate budget to provide for
Grants I'm amazed how small it is
so working with multiple agencies and
funding organizations requires knowledge
skills hard work and good working
relationships
to enable and Empower our communities
and groups to access the financial
support they require
just mentioned Community safety which of
course is an alliance of many agencies
due to the closer working and shared
information the management of
anti-social behavior is actually
producing results this week I'm going to
join the multidisciplinary teams in
great cornard to engage with the local
residents there listening to their views
and consider their solutions to the
problems of anti-social Behavior
much of the well-being work is
undertaken with abbeycroft leisure in
Sudbury and Hadley and the activities as
you can see from the report range from
holiday activity for children and
families to enabling and empowering
people suffering from mental health
dementia and loneliness to do positive
things within their communities and
Families
finally the cost of living and warm
spaces I've been able to visit many warm
spaces across the district
the grants team have paid out 30 grants
to support the provision of the warm
space in church halls and Village Halls
however there are many groups and clubs
outside of those 30 that are providing
this facility without recourse to
funding such as the generous Spirit of
our communities
however those groups or applied for a
grant and were not successful with the
warm space working have had their grants
stopped
officers presently are doing informal
visits to identify warm spaces to see
how they're operating and what they're
offering residents
in conclusion I would like to take this
opportunity to thank everybody in the
communities and well-being director as
they have done a fantastic job over the
past three months thank you chair
thank you Council McLaren
councilor Osborne
um yeah you know as as always the the
challenges are don't go away and it's
been really busy for the housing team
just as an indication of how hard they
have been working a total of 53
households were prevented or relieved
from homelessness
30 percent of these were rehoused into
the private sector compared to 19 in
quarter three the previous year 41
households were provided with emergency
b b or temporary accommodation and 11 of
these households included children are
not a good place to be
and ten homeless duties were discharged
by the central Suffolk Legends this is
almost double what was achieved in
quarter to quarter three last year
a rough sleeping there were 20 referrals
were received by the rough sleeping team
eight households at risk of rough
sleeping were provided with temporary
accommodation
and this figure was zero in quarter
three so that the previous year so this
shows how that workload is increasing
unfortunately
potency support officers secured just
under 20 400 for those referred for
financial support
this included new benefit Awards
discretionary housing payments and
funding from charitable applications
the housing team have introduced a new
voice and workflow module for our open
housing system this means all data and
voids progress can now be viewed within
the system rather than a spreadsheet
making it easy to know the status of any
void property and I must admit I'm
finding it a lot easier now to Monitor
and keep a check on it we've developed
new performance data dashboards that we
can track all voids and performance
following approval from cabinets in
November we have launched our tenant
engagement strategy and tenants received
a my home bulletin in December to alert
then that the strategy has been approved
and there has been a positive response
from some tenants already coming forward
to become more involved and work with us
which is great news
work continues on our Building Services
transformation and improvements program
and I know we're reporting on quarter
three but Mr chairman if I could just be
a little bit cheeky and I felt it
appropriate to Via details of a new
initiative and its houses for homes this
is the empty homes initiative operated
by the environmental health private
sector housing team of baber and
mid-suffolk District councils set up
with the aim of reducing the number of
long-term empty homes in the districts
and we all know the big part that
private landlords play in providing
homes for our people to live in so well
done to Justin and his team developing
this initiative and well down to the
housing team for all their hard work
they continue to do through the
thank you Mr chairman
thank you Council councilman visi
chairman
Mental Health
performance indicators flight tipping
um has dropped to pre-pandemic levels
um
report of 76 incidents
which is it's coming down
um waste subscribers for the brown bin
have has increased overall at 2.44 but
what I find disconcerting is that our
recycling waste collected continues to
hover around the 13.4 13.2 percent yes
it's a drop from the 16.1 in 2021 and
2022 at 16.2 um but it needs to be
further reduced and that will only
be just repeating
Souls what can and cannot be recycled
um
that last week I was at Chilton Depot
and I met members of the public realm
team
whose mowing regimes have changed
changed in order to encourage Wildflower
growth
but they're all running around with
little tablets
and they can immediately enter the data
that they need so that automatically
gets fed into the system and we're
beginning to
gather some good monitoring good
scheduling and good data
on health and safety and sustainable
environment
we've now got three solar compactor
smart bins in Sudbury and they're fully
operational and these do exactly what it
says on the tin
most food business
88 of the food businesses in Bieber have
a Food hygiene rating of five
team are working very very hard to get
that up to a much higher figure
thank you
um I just want to in councilor across
absence just go through some of the key
points from the uh the customers
information
um firstly
in quarter three there are an average of
375 calls per day and that's a reduction
of 32 in in calls from the previous
quarter
the average abandonment of course was 18
which was a decrease from 28 in quarter
two and the average wait time three
minutes 44 seconds and that's a decrease
from 5 minutes and 41 seconds in Quarter
Two
and there's also there are also a total
of 520 visits to the customer access
points and Hadley shot the own Sudbury
over that quarter three period so um and
that's an increase slightly about by
three percent
but um uh although with 1 711 visits
um in the year to date this does
represent only 50 of the pre-covered
visits over the same period in 2019 to
2020 so access point visits are
significantly down
um now that may be the fact that people
are using other means to uh to access
our services there were
2026 chat Bots and 912 automated
telephone sessions although that does
represent a decline on on the previous
quarter a chatbot activity decreased by
34 and automated telephone sessions were
down by 48 percent
um complaints are creeping up a bit
there are 193 complaints in quarter
three only one fewer than Quarter Two
however year on year it represents
increases of 13.4 percent and a further
8.5 that was for 20 21-22 and a further
8.5 increase from 2022 to 23.
most complaints that is 37 of them
relate to Building Services
um asset compliance next on the list of
26 percent Asset Management 13 uh were
the next most complaint about services
97.7 of non-major planning decisions
were decided on time and ranks of
District 23rd out of all local
authorities in England which is a pretty
good performance
um just a bit of information about our
uh online presence of 53 000 Twitter
Impressions
um and in the past quarter and it's the
first quarter that those Impressions
have increased since quarter one of 20
20 to 21 when they're highest of 212 000
and there are 126 647
um uh Facebook reaches and and this is
the second quarter that um our reach has
increased since data was the first
reported in quarter one of 2020-21
although it has fallen from a high of
000 uh in quarter four twenty twenty to
twenty one which is at the peak of the
Omicron variant of of um uh covid
um and then it decreased down to just
over 61 000 in the first quarter of this
year so um uh there is a variable
activity on online but it is quite
substantial
so that um really I think concludes the
the uh the various reports and does
anyone have any questions about this
okay councilman Hinton do you have
anything you we should ask
so members of the cabinet will move into
debate does anyone have anything to do
wait councilor arthi
any comments really
um the first one um is
um about customers and
um the
um
wait times and abandonment right which
I've been quite a Critic of in the past
so I think we should recognize and
welcome the fact that both of those
figures are coming down
councilor malvisi highlighted
um the 13 and a half percent of
recyclables um collect
then rejected and I think that's quite
an important figure and you know we've
still got more work to do on this
because it's unfortunate that you know
we're going around collecting
um Blue Bean contents we're taking them
to the Murph
and they're being rejected so we've got
a bit more work to do there and then
finally just a comment um
the um on the communities section
um I noticed that there's a lot on
community grants
um there's a there are a couple of brief
mentions of sill
um but it is the community
infrastructure Levy and the next um
we'll be dealing with is
um the silk bids I just wondered if in
the future we ought to have a little bit
more on sale in the community section
um we have got a couple of mentions
about the review but I wonder if we
ought to have a little bit more about
what Sill's actually providing in terms
of delivered projects in our communities
I think that's a very good point because
it is quite an important aspect of our
funding of community projects um both
obviously in terms of the the money that
neighborhoods get through the the
neighborhood component but also
um the central funds that we hold and
and increasingly
um allocating to to projects
I think that that makes sense if we can
do that
I'm sure we can
I'm seeing lots of nods yes yeah yes am
I in that direction yeah
okay
um
any other comments from anyone
Castle Busby
I'm concerned that we are we're entering
into project overload
um
we have an economy presentation last
week which was excellent and if you look
at the report here you can see that
there's an all
a lot of things that a lot of projects
that are going on and I'm just concerned
what kind of evaluation we undertake on
new projects
as to what the benefits are likely to be
if there's any
Financial figure on that and the cost to
deliver
um
there's a temptation to say we've got
all this work therefore we need to
increase staff numbers
and we can't afford to keep including
staff members we don't have the funds
for that some of these projects I think
we need to evaluate closer and maybe
decide that we don't do some
need to set some kind of priorities
whether a Fiona would like to comment on
that first well I'll comment and I think
uh the chief executive probably wants to
comment as well but my view is I think
that um
uh we we do
um assess projects before proceeding
with them in terms of
um their suitability viability and
necessity
um
I certainly see that within the economic
development team that the work that's
that's done there the projects that they
undertake
um and those that are going to bring
real benefit to our our district to
businesses and our communities so um I
think that there is a rigorous
assessment that is carried out yes there
are a lot but um that just goes to show
that that there's a lot of work that
needs to be done and that can and should
be done by us but I'll um pass over to
the chief executive for uh further
comment
I think
I think engineering's project overload
we are in Project overload exactly what
I was going to say so yes we are already
in that position and I'm confident
saying that because that's what our peer
review said
um in the middle of last year confirming
that we are punching above our weight
we're doing fantastic things
um but we can't just keep doing that and
doing that more and more and more
um not just for financial reasons and
sometimes we're the wrong people to
necessarily lead a project and some work
sometimes we're absolutely the right
people
um as the leaders alluded to we already
have fairly robust systems in place in
terms of is this project going to add
value but we have tied into that
recently so the we've introduced uh
what's known as a good start board that
is specifically to do that to evaluate
in more detail how is this project going
to have an impact what is the impact
we're expecting to see and is it the
best value I.E if you were to put this
project up against three or four others
is this the one you would pick
necessarily so we are implementing that
as we speak but we'll need to keep that
under constant review and particularly
good portfolio it does link back
inevitably to how much resource do we
have at the end of the day to be able to
invest in what variety of things
okay it's good um yeah again the concern
is that by being by tackling too many
things
there's a danger that we don't do the
important things
quickly enough and well enough
because the resources spread thinly I
think we have got some very key projects
on the go at the moment and I'd hate to
see them
slide because we're involved in too many
other things
thank you Council Busby um valid points
I think
certainly is let's see if you did
executive said we're tightening up on
the
assessment and
um effectively the the monitoring of
projects indeed
the way we go about deciding the
prioritization and which ones to proceed
with so
um we need we need to keep an eye on it
but um thank you for bringing to our
attention
we can't solve The World's problems
though we'd like to try we're just
trying to solve baber's problems I've
got another point they're the the waste
sites you mentioned that the
usage had dropped since pre-covered
and I wonder whether that was because we
Now operate an appointment
process and whether if we reverted back
to
just driving in it might increase the
amount I mentioned the access points
um such as access yeah yeah
no no no that's that's County
responsibility not ours so I was talking
about the Sudbury Hadley in shortly
customer access points
yeah no problem
Council McLaren
the uh thank you chair can I just go
back to the projects I would find it
very helpful
say a list of the current projects
some not clear enough to know which all
of them are going on but it would be
very helpful to me to say yeah the
number of what they are yeah
yeah thank you okay thank you
Council Busby so to come back
um
I'm too convinced about seal coming in I
think you get plenty of opportunity to
shout how good you are you guys and we
appreciate that you are doing a good job
too much into here it dilutes the other
stuff I think you could put it into the
communities as part of the grant scheme
but
wary about extending this report any
longer than it is
one concern I do have on the environment
is that we we talk about
the tree
work that we did in terms of
the canopy survey
and the new the
tree planting strategy that we've got
I mean I've written to Tom so he's not
going to be surprised at what I'm going
to about to say which is which I think
we forget
and don't give enough importance to the
historic trees that we've already got
we've lost a couple I think couple in
Bentley recently because
we were either too slow or didn't
consider them important enough to put
tpls on
the Bentley have raised a concern that
they're likely to lose more
if
but we seem slow in defending what we've
currently got rather than again putting
the effort into
new things well
new trees are great and I haven't got a
thing to say against that I think we
should be doing that but I think we just
need to put some more emphasis on the
stuff that we've already got
okay thanks for that
um that's a valid point yeah if there
are
um significant uh old trees which are at
risk and don't have tpos and then we do
need to act promptly to
um if if that's the appropriate way of
going in order to preserve them well for
instance we have a project
um or an app planning application that's
likely to come forward in Bentley which
is called broccoli wood
mining
um and also waste processing so the
project is expanded as a result of which
I think 24 key trees are likely to be
lost
well if they've got a TPO on them
because they are important and they are
important because the part of really
historic Woods then that might give us
an extra strength in determining whether
the planning should go ahead or not if
they haven't got tpos on
the applicants like say well they can't
be that important because they haven't
got a TPO
and you just need to be wary of
losing once you've lost a 200 year old
oak John
then you've lost it
and it doesn't matter how many
saplings we plant is they're not going
to make up for it really
and I understand that I think is it have
we got more historic trees as a district
than any other or something or certainly
in this area I think so we need to
protect them
yeah okay
um Fair Point and we probably we'll
we'll look into that customer visi
thank you chair
um yes councilor Busby has is making a
valid point
um
and one of the things that uh
had to start in order to achieve the
green canopy
was we needed to know what trees we had
and where they had them
because unfortunately this knowledge or
information
was sort of held by town and Parish
councils some did no and some didn't
know well now we've mapped the area
we've recorded the data
on its own GIS software
and it will assist with the monitoring
and maintaining of those sites but
because we know what we've got and where
it is we can now go to the next phase
which is educating the parish councils
and town councils to
get their trees tpoed
move forward you know we need to engage
and talk we need to educate so we are
moving on to the next step
I do have to say
that baber has been put forward for an
award
on the work it's done on the green
canopy
and that's taking place on Wednesday
thank you councilman
it would be remiss of me if I didn't
come back and say I think it's hard to
blame the parish councils for not
getting the trees TPO Bentley has tried
for months to try and get some and
they've done everything they possibly
can apart from living them to get some
trees tpoed uh I don't think he's down
to the parishes I'm sorry I think it's
internal resourcing uh we probably
haven't got enough resource in that area
and there's probably too many
items for the resource that we've got to
deal with so I think it's an internal
issue
the realm is better equipped
team got their tablets and things so
they know where the trees are
so
the data internally is more quickly
accessed
and therefore they'll be able to respond
more quickly
we're getting there it
it asked us some of us would like but we
are getting
there thank you
right I think it's probably time we drew
this to a close a bit of a digression
onto trees but nonetheless interesting
and useful
so that's that's it the course three
performance report is noted there's no
vote on this
moving on item 11 paper BCA 2247
Community infrastructure Levy
um the cell expenditure program for
March 2023 I'd like to invite the
cabinet member for planning to introduce
this report counselor Rafi
thank you chairman
um
you are now all familiar with the format
and I hope that you're also familiar
with the fact that cabinet has the
responsibility to determine bids twice
yearly so
um
I won't go into detail
um on the bids but refer you of course
to appendix B which has the full
technical assessments and
and Christine Thurlow from the Seal team
is here and I'm sure she can answer them
there are five bids for you to consider
today
affecting the parishes of Stutton Capel
Saint Mary monks Ely Sudbury and Edward
Stone
so just to briefly run through those
e2211 is Stutton which is a new activity
room they're looking for a hundred
thousand pounds you'll remember that
that is now our new maximum for
Community projects
and that represents 74 of the total
eligible project costs
and this is to provide the village hall
with a new activity room and the
provision of a new toilet that's also
designed to disabled access standards
and that is recommended to you for
approval
the second one is
b2203 in cable St Mary where they're
looking to provide play area
improvements at the existing playing
field again the seal bid is for 100 000
pounds and this time represents sorry 53
of the total project costs
it's
um for an update of the existing
facility which is outdated and not fit
for purpose for a community as you know
that have seen significant housing
growth
there's evidence of wide Community
Support
um to provide additional Leisure and
Community facilities and of course it
encourages active outdoor play for
children
I know that you like to know where money
comes from for these schemes and this
one includes
quite a lot of collaborative spend
with our cell funding and cable
Community Trust putting money into it
and the parish council along with some
unspent one section 106 developer
contributions as well again that's
recommended for your approval
third one is b2210 in Monks Ely again
play area the seal bed here is 51 068
pounds and this time represents 65 of
the total project costs we put these
percentages in because you'll remember
that we've got not only
um the newly uplifted hundred thousand
pound limit but we've also got a 75
maximum contribution from Sil
so again this is providing additional
play equipment at the existing
playground area
Village has seen some growth in recent
Years you'll remember that some of the
seal payments are still outstanding in
monk Sealy but they have got a
development of 17 new houses which is on
the old Primary School site so we expect
additional families to be moving into
the village
who can benefit from the new facilities
so again that's recommended for your
approval and it has wide local support
as well
moving on to
b2216 in Sudbury and this is for a new
artificial pitch
for sub United Football Club
um it's a little bit of a hundred
thousand pounds
um which is ten percent of the total
project costs
um
the project is is a part of a series of
proposals
to improve the the site so they'll have
also additional facilities for disabled
car parking spaces and a new unit for
use by the club for catering purposes
I'm sure you're familiar with AFC
Sudbury and we're excited they've been
working in partnership with other groups
and organizations
um
who they are it's the bridge who work
with disadvantaged adults
including picking up issues such as
dementia learning disabilities and
mental health issues they work with
local schools and the active Suffolk
partnership
and they also have inclusive programs
designed for women and girls to promote
recreational provision in these groups
the construction of a new pitch will not
will enable them to increase their
provision
and benefit both local and wider
communities
they also do a lot of work with all age
groups so the new pitch will have no
restriction on who can use the facility
so it will benefit
ages 3 upwards basically
with no restriction but I'm guessing
that um some of us are probably past
playing football
not only because of the risks that it
can present but because there comes in
age when we probably don't play any
longer
so it has the full support of the
Football Association the fa and they've
sent in a letter of support the only
Rider on this one is that you will note
that it is subject to planning
permission
so that planning permission is has not
been granted yet that's still
outstanding so you'll see that the beard
is recommended to you today subject to
the grant of planning permission
finally moving to Edward Stone and we're
back to another bid for play equipment
it's a seal bid of 11 444
445 pounds so it's just above the 10th
10th choirs cabinet approval it's 75 of
the total eligible costs and
um it's for the provision of new play
equipment
including and punctuation is really
important here including a four Tower
multi-unit
seesaw and resurfacing of the ground the
reason Punctuation is important is
because it may have sounded like a four
Tower seesaw that's not
a four-time multi-unit the seesaw
resurfacing of the ground so that it can
boost all around a year all year round
so
if I can propose please chairman the
recommendations at paragraph 3.1 to
approve these bids
and also at 3.2 to note and endorse the
sil expenditure program at appendix a
which is Page 97 of your report and that
also of course as is usual includes the
full history of projects sillbids and
your previous approvals
thank you Council bluffy may I have a
second to please
Castle Rose Bowl
any questions from members of the
cabinet
counselor Hinton do you have any
questions
councilor Adrian Osborne you have a
question
well it's um it's just perhaps something
that cancer last year's forgotten as
I'll remembers of any football club can
do walk in football now
yes that sounds like a
a more realistic activity okay so can I
say chairman it sounds so entertaining
that I might even go and watch councilor
Osborne doing
okay
um right moving into debate does anyone
wish to say anything about councilor
Busby
yeah if you look at all the all the bids
the the
silt takes up a portion of it but the
funds come from other places as well it
just concerns me that monks Ely have
actually put nothing towards this their
player improvements
still counts of 51 000 section 106 is
twenty seven thousand and that covers
the total cost of the project which is
fine but it doesn't kind of suggest that
their
putting much effort into it themselves
and councilor Arthur would you like to
um
I think perhaps they might have put in
some of their own neighborhood still had
they been in receipts of a little bit
more
um so this I did mention that the seal
collection in monk Sealy for the 17 new
homes has had a little bit of a
um a little bit of a problem and Debbie
osak that recovery officer is chasing
that payment there has been an offer as
well of perhaps changing the houses to
um I think I can say all this in public
session can't take there's also been an
offer from the developer to actually
change the houses
um to social housing and that hasn't um
that hasn't come to fruition yet so I
think it's a little bit difficult for
monk Sealy to contribute because they
haven't got the money at the moment
s there are other sources apart from
Silver to provide funds
um maybe
um I said earlier on that we've got
Christine here to help us with detailed
questions that sounds like a detailed
question
Christine can you help with that
uh in terms of I mean you've answered
the question and or discussed the the
situation regarding neighborhood sale I
mean in this particular case there was
section 106 that was unspented it was
important to get it spent and this was a
project that the parish wanted to take
forward while they wait to develop any
other projects that may come forward
should any neighborhood still be
forthcoming so we assisted with bringing
this project forward so they could do
something for the benefit of the of
their Parish
thank you Christine
Council Osborne
yeah thank you Mr German I think it's
great that these bids are coming forward
and the baby can Atomic accommodate them
I think you know all these improvements
I see and how many have we done over
ever ever since seal came into into
being so I think it's great in regards
to the Sudbury one absolutely 100
support it and
project they do a fantastic job I've
witnessed it firsthand and it's it's
fantastic what they do so I shall be
sought she'll be supporting this
together with all the other bids that
are in place thank you
thank you thank you Council McLaren
as I sit on the cell room review group
when we put the
amounts up to 100
South debates but what is interesting is
to see that we've got three bids here
that we actually use in that amount it's
really good and I'm fully supporting the
Stockton
development because it will enhance the
Community Hall no end to the benefit of
many many groups
residents that use it thank you chair
yeah I I agree these are five very good
and very worthy
projects for sale funding the
the one at Sudbury AFC is is
particularly exciting I think because
it's a club that's going from strength
to strength and to have a new artificial
pitch and to have further development of
that site is is only to for the good of
Sudbury and particularly in terms of the
the growing population in Sudbury in
that area
to have a good thriving football club
like this is excellent
then particularly the season before last
they did get to the first round of the
FA Cup will be getting knocked out by
Colchester but it is a club that um uh
has Ambitions which is which is
excellent
castle of Busby
yes a surprise we don't really support
certain members
from Sudbury and their surroundings and
here's another big project that we are
fully behind but uh
yes the reality
um uh is somewhat different from the
perception I think in terms of that but
um it's going to take a while to change
people's perceptions
okay
um Council rathi just before we finish
I'd like to take the opportunity to
thank Christine and her team
um Joey's here today as well
in the Autumn as you probably know it's
part of the work that we're committed to
do with seal we had a briefing session
for parish councils and for um
to attend as well it was really really
well attended and got some fantastic
feedback from it so to also credit the
team with that as well because I think
there are a lot of Parish councils and
perhaps some members who are still not
fully up to speed with the seal process
what they can do with neighborhood sale
what they can bid for from us and that
was a really successful really well
presented briefing that was done so just
to express my thanks to the team for
everything they do
I think we would all like to uh
reiterate that so thank you Christy
okay then um it's probably time we move
to the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
thank you chair that's six months for
that's unanimous
thank you
item 12 paper BCA 2248 private sector
housing enforcement and civil penalties
policy
I'd like to invite the cabinet member
for housing to introduce this report
councilor Osborne
the private renter sector contributes
towards meeting housing needs in the
district most landlords provide good
standard accommodation for their tenants
and manage their property properties
satisfactorily but this is not so in all
cases the report proposes a new
enforcement policy for our private
sector housing work it outlines the
current work of our housing standards
team which is responsible for ensuring
that housing conditions are safe and
healthy for residents which is a
statutory Council Duty
heart the enforcement policy seeks to
provide Clarity for landlords and agents
on what is expected from them and the
response they can expect from the
council to service requests in most
cases this involves advice and
encouragement to meet minimum legal
standards the policy also outlines
guidelines for officers to ensure
enforcement is taken consistently fairly
and using good and fair practice
wherever possible we prefer to work with
landlords in order to resolve problems
to improve standards officers
occasionally come across situations
where housing conditions are extremely
poor and vulnerable people are left at
unacceptable risk to their safety and
health for example poor face poor start
again poor fire safety precautions in
houses in multiple occupations
inadequate Heating and overcrowding
sometimes officers encounter situations
where they need to use formal powers
in the most extreme cases officers work
with other agencies such as the police
and the fire service and have been
actively dealing with dangerous and
criminal activities relating to rented
housing such as modern day slavery in
our districts
the report proposes to charge for
officer and administrative time to
recover costs where formal action must
be taken when it has to resort to use to
use such powers
this policy is not intended to prescribe
the action that will be taken in every
situation it will guide officers when
investigating cases serving notices or
taking enforcement action including
legal proceedings
it is important that officers have the
option to make use of all powers
available to them the government has
given powers to local authorities to
take stronger action where it is
Justified in the private rented sector
these are known as civil penalties and
are an alternative to prosecution
they enable us to penalize the worst
landlords through direct Financial
sanctions or prosecution and will only
be used serious offense be used whereas
a serious offense or where compliance
cannot be achieved
the council has developed its civil
penalties approach outlined in appendix
2 after collaboration with colleagues in
Suffolk and liaison with our legal
department
this will ensure that penalties are
proportionate to the offense and applied
fairly
there is a system of receiving
representations against the imposition
of a fine and a legal appeal available
in these cases it is in line with the
government's intention to prevent
landlords from benefiting from unlawful
Behavior the council intends to use
these Powers sparingly only where
Justified and generally where
enforcement action has failed to obtain
compliance any penalties received will
be retained in the team's budget
before recommending approval to those
outlined in this report I asked members
to look at appendix 5 which provides
feedback from scrutiny and the minutes
which has been circulated as a hard copy
at this meeting also a thank you to
Justin David and his team for putting
this policy together it's a lot of hard
work gone into this and it's it's a very
good policy I I feel I therefore
recommend members agree to
recommendation to Cabinet option one as
stated at paragraphs 3.1 to 3.5 and this
is to adopt the new private rented
sector housing enforcement policy
include of approving and authorizing the
use of the civil and financial penalty
Powers is also to agree a fair charging
regime to recover the costs of housing
enforcement action taken by the council
and to retain Revenue arising from civil
penalties the reasons for agreeing the
recommendations are to ensure that the
consistent and effective policy to
tackle poor conditions in private sector
housing thank you Mr chairman
thank you Council Osborne may I have a
second to please
councilor Busby
any questions for councilor Osborne
nope
councilor Hinton do you have any
questions
no questions Mr chairman but just to say
that the minutes have been circulated
clearly show that the overview and
scrutiny committee looked at this in
some detail there were some concerns
about uh registers of private landlords
and things like that which obviously
will be developed over time
and publicity regarding enforcement
action that has been that is taken
against individuals and I think they'll
cover all the recommendations that
overview and scrutiny adopted are well
and truly coveted within the
recommendations before you today
thank you Council Hinton
moving back to the cabinet does anyone
wish to say anything now we're into
debate
councilor Busby
I feel a bit
nervous I guess about putting pressure
on private
landlords and we've got such a
big job ourselves to do with our own
housing
it's a bit hypocritical really but um
we need to do it
we need to sort our own house out as
well
um thank you councilor Busby yeah um
we we do and and this isn't um
a way of um
sort of diverting attention or
um uh the focus away from work that we
need to do on our own but uh there is a
recognition that
um private housing is obviously with
owner occupation but also the private
rented sector is 17 does represent a
considerable part of the housing stock
in the district and we do need to make
sure that
and private tenants have the
um
the the homes that are available within
that sector are are um fit and and of
good quality but I think the important
thing is that this this this is an
enforcement policy and and um the
ability to use civil penalties
um as a as an alternative to um
prosecution and and and that's going to
I think make it more effective that we
can can move forward with a way of
ensuring better quality within the
private rental sector
Council Osborne
thank you Mr Jimmy I absolutely agree
with your comment it is important
um that we make sure the private sector
are providing a good standard of housing
um and you're right at the same time we
need to make sure that we're doing the
same job as well and that's exactly what
we're doing with this diagnostic work
and the transformation plan that's in
place so the two will go working side by
side so that when the work is in place
then we can be assured all members could
be assured members of the public can be
assured that not only are is our own
housing stock being looked at and being
cared for to a high standard but also
the private sector is in exactly the
same situation so I don't think we're
being hypocritical at all I think we're
Forward Thinking and making sure that
both sectors are in a good position
can I can I can I just add to that as
well I think you you have alluded to it
Mr chairman we must forget the private
sector play a big role in providing
housing to help us prevent homelessness
and we need to work with them and part
of this policy is to not work against
them to work with them and to support
them to ensure that they're providing a
high standard thank you
thank you that's that's
um
a point that's well put there Council
Osborne it's it's um it's a
collaborative approach rather than
anything else Council McLaren
okay it just crossed my mind
sources and the skills require
some Dewey
resources to
do with skills and knowledge thank you
Council Roswell
we do
um I I will go for a more complicated
David who's to answer questions but
we'll
want policy for approval if we didn't
have the resources to follow it through
David can you expand on that please
yes we do have the resources to go ahead
with this policy as it stands we are a
largely reactive service at the moment
but we do have um the ability as well to
to deal with um situations as they as
they develop and some of these referrals
from the police and the Fire Authority
we have been working with them
proactively
thank you thank you for that
Council Rafi
yeah it's just following on really from
what council of husband said and I'm
always a believer in a carrot
ahead of a stick and this is the stick
but there's very little in here about
what we can do to help there is a
section on advice advice to the tenant
and advice to the landlord but it's
advice to the landlord about his duties
it's not advice to the landlord about
what we can actually offer to help
and one of those is I think we recently
agreed what we did recently agreed to
continue with our interest-free loans to
landlords and I think it would actually
be useful
it depends who you think this policy is
for but I mean it would be useful if we
had some sort of a commitment to
actually offer advice to landlords about
how we can actually help them with some
of the improvements that may be found to
be necessary
and the the loans were specifically for
bringing
empty homes back in into use but um I
don't know Castle Osborne do you wish to
comment
in terms of what concert office just
said
it does detail
s to do this and to do that as the
chairman has alluded to we do offer a
loan of 20 000 but that is to bring
empty homes back into occupation it's
not in really in relation to making
homes of a standard that they should be
um I don't know if David wants to add
any more to that
not really Council of all the sport and
I think you've covered that quite well
the enforcement policy I would say does
um there are there is a lot of content
around collaboration using the powers
only as a last resort and working with
landlords and so let me
um you know we don't take enforcement
action likely we've always prefer in
most cases to work with landlords and
and
Paul they do contact us
um we don't we do go out and see them
and offer advice and that's always our
our initial response to these cases I
mean I think at the other end where
there is criminal activity
obviously really along those kind of
lines so that we can effectively tackle
really serious problems when we need to
so
I mean I'd give it a Give an example as
well if the we've done a lot of work on
the on the energy performance
certificates with landlords and with our
colleagues in Suffolk and that really
has been about engaging with them
getting them on board and being
proactive and giving them advice about
how they can um comply with those
requirements and uh
um I think one of the appendices
specifically covers the energy
performance work and is particularly
like touch as well so that that should
um frame us out with our kind of
informal response is in in that
situation
thank you David and I think the
important thing is that
without this then we would be entirely
Reliant upon prosecution
um which would be obviously it's a it's
a it's a heavier
weapon in our Arsenal but um it's it's
something we can't use as effectively or
as often so this is this is just
something that will allow us to do
things that we wouldn't be able to do if
we were to rely purely on on prosecution
to enforce standards
anyone else councilman VC
it's a bottomless pit or it can be
um and in the last year or there are
both
I've seen what happens when you go to
the other end of the scale
like they've done in Scotland where
nobody is allowed to be evicted
for non-payment of rent
so the end result is that you've got an
awful lot of properties that are blocked
the owners can't get paid they can't get
rid of the 10 the
alleged tenants and it's having a huge
detrimental impact on the entire housing
stock of Scotland
so
a heavy stick is one step too far and
the other ones just off the wall so I I
find this a very good policy
and I'm supportive of it
thank you
any other coins Council Rossi well can I
just ask another question with regard to
um empty homes because you mentioned
that our loans were only available for
empty
I did something like good point but it
doesn't apply here but I think it does
doesn't it because it's in somewhere in
here it says what our policy principles
are
um
and I think
bringing empty homes back into use is
part of trying to find it now is part of
it isn't it
thank you very much page 169 the council
Hinton tells me
yes
um so the policy aims to ensure private
sector housing is not left empty for an
unreasonable amount of time all becomes
an eyesore a nuisance to neighboring
homes I would have thought this is
exactly where bringing landlords
attention to
um interest-free loans might be
appropriate have I got that wrong
thank you Mr Jim yeah if a landlord
comes to us for advice and guidance and
the property is shown to be empty then
of course we will advise them that that
loan is available if they come to if we
find that they're in breach of the
standards that you should be applying in
respect of a property that's already
occupied then we can't offer them that
loan that is there for just for empty
homes but the the advice and guidance
will will still be there and I'm sure
there may be other funds available that
the team will signpost landlords to to
ensure that they can bring the house up
to standard if it's through lack of
resources
thank you Council Oswald
any other comments
right then I think we can move to the
vote on this
hey chair that vote is now in progress
that is six votes full that's unanimous
thank you item 13 paper BCA 2249 update
on the social housing regulations and
the outcome of the referral to the
regulator of social housing black invite
the cabinet member for housing to
introduce this report councilor Osborne
key requirements for all social
landlords including local Authority
landlords with more than one thousand
properties
the regulatory changes will also include
updating and strengthen the powers of
the regulator and housing Ombudsman
service implementing a proactive
consumer regulating regime regime
through formalizing inspections and
strengthening the current standards
against which landlords are regulated
and requiring them to be transparent
about their performance and decision
making
this enables tenants and the regulator
to hold social landlords to account put
things right when they go wrong and
listen to tenants through effective
engagement
this paper provides an update on our
work around social housing regulation
and compliance following our referral to
the regulator for social housing
to ensure we meet our obligations we
must have a governance structure the
regulator expects members to have
oversight of all compliance issues and
this includes gas inspections
electrical safety checks fire safety
asbestos and legionelli lifts I think I
pronounced that right in addition
following the tragic events in Rochdale
the regulator has concluded that damp
and mold must be reported via a
governance structure as well
structure where compliance is reported
at cabinet would give assurance that
members have oversight this forms part
of the consumer's standards and is
critical
consumer standards covers all aspects of
housing therefore as with the Building
Services performance the housing team
will be reporting high-level key
performance indicators
this paper sets out the suggested format
following our self-referral and
subsequent regulator judgment the
regulator said they would give us time
to work on our compliance and contact us
in a month
as such we have not yet received
correspondence from the regulator
I would now like to propose approval to
the recommendations 3.1 to 3.4 outlined
in this report and both myself and the
director of housing will be happy to
take any questions thank you Mr chair
thank you Council Oswald may I have a
second to please
councilor malvesi thank you any
questions Council rathi yes the obvious
question really which is that um we've
got some figures in the report which I'm
guessing are now out of date and I'm
guessing that somebody's turn up today
to update us on the latest figures
Council Osborne do we have any update on
the numbers here are they probably about
a week old these ones I've only I've got
the figures provided to other cabinet
men and bearing in mind this data
changes from day to day and so it's very
difficult to be able to provide up to
the minute if you like like data what I
will say is that I did a quick
calculation this morning on the data
that we have got to hand
and three of those properties that are
non-compliant when I reported at full
Council on the compliance five percent
of our properties were non-compliant
today when I did that calculation three
percent of properties of our total
number of properties are non-compliant
so that figure is going down all the
time it's gone down four Council was
only was it last week we had four
Council yeah so that's it's gone down by
two percent in in less than a week and
we need to bear in mind that also that
three percent 99 if not 100 is due to
access issues which we are working on
um I don't know if our director of
housing has anything to add to that
thank you um so before Deborah uh picks
up on that so that three percent uh
that's only about a hundred properties
then out of our total stock which is
about 3 600 something like that yeah
Deborah
thank you I'm happy to provide the
latest
um overview of where we are with
compliance with the minutes if if that's
helpful
um we we do have an update uh I do I do
get an update from the compliance Team
every week and I'll provide that to the
portfolio holders
um every other week
um so so happy to provide that the
latest one to go with minutes
thank you thanks Deborah
Council Rossi could we have the figures
because in the report it was Electric
electrical testing 109 gas inspection 66
CO detectors 146 smoke detectors 1013
and I presume that has changed
yes it may have changed by tomorrow but
that doesn't mean that there's no point
in having to fix
it would you like me to read them out
what would you do so then please yeah
that'd be great if you've got them thank
you okay so so
um gas
we currently have 59 overdue
electrical testing 105.
fire safety
so this is fire risk assessments we've
got two outstanding and that relates to
a couple of um it's front doors from
some leaseholder flats and we are taking
some legal action
um with that because they're refusing to
change them
um detector so so smoke detector we've
got a thousand and two but I must
emphasize that doesn't mean that we've
got a thousand and two properties with
no smoke detectors
um it means we are providing an
additional smoke detector and replacing
those that are um you know past their
their date
um
water testing so this is Legionella and
this tends to be in the sheltered
housing stock we've got 17 overdue
that's actually because of an I.T
um failure but they're booked in for the
23rd of March so so confident that
there'll be
um completed then
um our CEO detectors our carbon monoxide
detectors
um we've now completed all those
so so that's um a very positive picture
um but just so you can take some time to
have a look at this in more detail I'll
I'll
um still put it in the minutes if that's
helpful thank you very much Deborah
thank you so can I follow on from the
question then so um As I understood it
when the report was prepared all of the
outstanding gas
and truck failed to access the
properties so it now looks as though
whether it's because people have come
back from holidays or cruises or
whatever they've been it now looks as
though we're starting to get access to
those properties and as so far have we
actually had to get any orders for entry
or not
down that road so as of yet we haven't
been issued any injunctions however I
expect we will because you always get a
small number of people who for whatever
reason won't let us in what we are doing
is we're taking
um we're doing some parallel planning
with those so as well as going down the
court route our neighborhood officers
are our door knocking because often it's
it's due to vulnerabilities and and you
know health issues and that's why people
um don't want to let us in
um so so that's where we are at the
moment
thank you Deborah
Council Osborne
just add to that to
the neighborhood team out there trying
to knock on doors and trying to support
people because for whatever reason
mental health problems and still some
people quite rightly so they are after
covid they don't want to let people
strange people into their homes so that
is still an issue as well and so we've
got people that knock on doors and try
and support those people to enable us to
have access so there's a lot of work
going in to make sure that we can do all
we can because the injunction really we
don't like going down that route but we
have to to be abiding by the law so
we're already doing the neighborhood
team visits as well
are we including tenant boards in this
process
we have have we gone to the tennis court
Deborah with the compliance I know we
different other things but happy on the
compliance
um so so we we haven't yet because we
haven't had a meeting but as part of our
governance structure the um tenant board
will be getting regular updates
um as will other groups so as we start
to develop more of our resident
involvement
um we'll be reaching out to more
residents and it might be you know
estate meetings
um it it might be sort of you know door
knocking whatever it might be but we'll
have a variety of opportunities to be
updating our residents
thank you Jeff thank you any other
questions Council Busby
4.3 we talk about
um
having routine inspections for all
landlords with over a thousand homes
does it
once every four years did that mean they
inspect all the Thousand homes or do
they do a random sample or
how's that work
so so that actually relates to an
in-depth assessment which is provided
which is carried out by the regulator of
social housing and that will be
um for all landlords which have got over
a thousand properties so they don't
inspect the properties what they do is
they come and inspect us so it's like an
ofsted style inspection for those who
provide housing
thank you Council Osborne
it's a monitoring Arrangements does
include a quarterly report to the tenant
board
any other questions
Council Hinton do you have any questions
all right moving into debate does anyone
wish to um say anything in in debate
so we're happy with the the progress
um not just the numbers here but the
update that Deborah has given
sorry cancel
no it's just
I've just joining there's a debate to
say we've actually when this was first
reported to members and to our tenants
and to the members of public at large
um and it was pretty widely spread out
there it wasn't done behind closed doors
that we've got on a long way in a very
short period of time and that's due to
the excellent work of Deborah and her
team and I think we're in an okay pit
situation now it's not perfect but we're
in a much better situation than we were
a few weeks ago give us a few more weeks
and we'll be in an even better situation
and so we're okay and I think it's up to
members to make sure that
their residents you know are kept
informed and that their expectations are
kept to a level that is is right for
where we are in this situation and not
cause them to get anxiety and anxious
they've got enough of that as it is
without creating it anymore so I think
all members have a responsibility to do
that and I'm glad to see that where we
got the future governance and monitoring
Arrangements there'll be monthly updates
to cabinet members on a briefing basis
and then we'll be reported the cabinet
then then reported to on a quarterly
basis
um I just I think there might be a way
where we can report to all members a
little bit more frequently
um
exclude in the cabinet members because
they're going to get a monthly briefing
anyway as an exceptions so if there's a
situation where it's it's critical
situation or it's not in a good place
then I think we have to report to all
members by exception
um
rather than just the the cabinet members
on a on the briefing sessions
um I don't know if director of housing
agrees with me on that one but I think
it will assure members that if we're
getting into a position where things
aren't looking too good they will be
informed that that is the situation
she does agree she nodded she's nodding
yes we are we are thinking and
considering how we can further keep
um members updated because it's it's
really important actually part of the uh
regulatory framework
thank you Deborah uh I was going to say
um Council Osborne and the progress has
been excellent particularly now we've
down to zero outstanding on Asbestos and
as we've heard today zero outstanding on
on the carbon monoxide detectors which
is excellent and also of course um I
think
um the the confidence is going to be
high given that we're now identified all
the compliance areas the kpis and the
the governance and monitoring
Arrangements which I think are going to
be very effective and uh allow us to to
keep on top of this going forward
um and I'm sure that all of the other
councils up and down the country um are
struggling to um to put in place similar
arrangements and um
eventually
um the regulator of social housing which
has been set up to do a specific job
will be effective in ensuring that um uh
social housing stock everywhere is is of
the right standard which I know we all
we all want to see
Council arthi just to say full credits
uh councilor Osborne as well on the way
that she's dealt with and
it had the potential
um to cause
unnecessary concern
um if if people didn't
put this didn't quite understand exactly
what happened with the self-referral to
the regulator
and the issues around
overdue inspections as opposed to
a problem with the property it's the EXP
it's the inspections that are overdue
and I've got to say that I thought that
cancer was born was incredibly helpful
throughout the whole process so
compliments to as well
I would agree sorosemore has
used her knowledge and experience in in
the portfolio very effectively thank you
and only provide Clive with hourly
updates on the video
okay thank you very much
oh yeah I know City yeah and the team
the team's been excellent as
right if there are no further comments
on this we'll move to the vote please
that is six votes for a chair that's
unanimous thank you
item 14 paper BCA 2250 Weber mid-suffer
cultural heritage and visitor economy
strategy and as the cabinet member for
economic growth I will introduce this
paper
this is our first dedicated strategy to
provide a long-term Vision to support
the important cultural heritage and
visitor sectors of our economy which are
worth over 250 million pounds per year
to our two districts
a huge amount of work and engagement has
gone into producing the strategy to
ensure that it is robust comprehensive
and based on desk research extensive
engagement with cultural tourism and
Heritage businesses and also wider
industry Partners to support the
cross-party member and officer working
groups section 11 of the report provides
more detail about the stakeholder
engagement consultation
the aims of the strategy at sport
residents in Beiber and mid Suffolk to
live full coverage of lives building
cultural confidence and civic pride to
create a sustainable resilient cultural
heritage and visitor economy sector that
Champions the Region's distinctive
qualities and to support the culture
Heritage and visitor sectors to work
collaboratively with neighboring
organizations districts and counties to
trial new approaches
a number of objectives have been
identified for each of these aims and
these can be found in section B3 of the
strategy
and also to deliver the aims of strategy
will be framed around four key themes
firstly building building cultural
habits to improve the everyday
experience of residents and visitors
secondly accelerating progress through
developing the sector and its resilience
and also accelerating progress through
better use of data insight and digital
transformation and finally driving
collaborate collaboration to evolve
cultural heritage places and
destinations
and these themes are described in more
detail in section six of the report
it should be noted that this is not our
first engagement with our cultural
organizations and firm groundwork has
already been achieved over the last few
years through the television program
which has contributed to the formation
of cultural Vision groups in Sudbury and
Stone Market
this strategy will provide a clear
framework for these groups and others to
work together to make sustainable and
Progressive changes both district-wide
and at a local level
I think we can all agree that
development of this strategy in the
long-term Vision are important so that
we can support our many businesses in
these sectors enable them to ensure that
residents and visitors alike can fully
explore the great variety of attractions
that our districts have to offer and of
course support the growth of the local
economy
I'd like to ask for a second to please
thank you
members of the cabinet any questions
Council Busby
yeah only on the actual
pathetic I know but what what on Earth
is that a picture of on the first page
the animal it looks like it's got two
horns and no face uh it's a ghost isn't
it
really
it's a goat yes it's definitely goat
it's the greatest of all time is it okay
I should have realized
any other questions
Council Hinton do you have any questions
chairman yes
um
this is exercise the parish council in
my award as much as as me is
in that uh one of the things that is
perhaps missing
is an ability to generate
uh
a picture of what is available in the
area rather than just individual little
symbols all over the place
you look at the Star Valley all the way
from
Manning tree to Sudbury
there are four World acclaimed artists
who were residents in that area and
painted in that area
they could be put together as a package
to encourage people to to come to the
area and see where they painted but then
also we could add on to that
if we didn't let the developers bulldoze
them flat but that's another story
um
aspects of the life that they were
involved in when they were here
in Dedham there are all sorts of places
I know it's over that Iron Curtain
called the boundary between Essex and
Suffolk
but there are two important painters who
live there constable and his family
operated all the way around East
burkhold and a Brick Kiln that was
originally associated with them was dug
up on a or discovered shall I say on the
buildings development in the village and
before anything much was done with it
apart from a couple of photographs taken
that went in the East England it was
covered over again
allegedly on health and safety grounds
how on Earth it could have been a risk
when it was only about three foot deep
and it had an iron fence all the way
around it and it was at the far side of
a field I don't know but that was
another story so we could put together
more of a package of what is available
within our district for people to look
at including of course
better mention it as we've got a couple
of separate people here gainsborough's
house and and Thomas Gainsborough and
his painting but he was just one of
those four
shouldn't ignore the others because
they're equally well known across the
world
if all people got to do is to look at it
online
our tourism's dead
thank you councilor Hinton um before I
ask Zoe Pat to to comment I think the
the idea of packages like that there's
something that we are aware of not just
for
um the artistic Heritage but other
things like the um uh The Vineyards
um and and there are other packages that
can can be put together and these things
have been discussed but um perhaps um so
you'd like to comment further
yep just to say that um thank you for
your comment
um under theme three
um there's a whole section around
driving collaboration to involve to
evolve cultural heritage places
and destinations so there will be a
large piece of work that will come out
of this shaping up itineraries for a
place what the offer is for for visitors
and that in that particular a part of
part of our district and as you say
working working across borders as well
so we're not looking at this as a as an
isolated piece of work we will be
working with our partners across uh
different uh
councils and organizations outside of
our districts to kind of bring in that
much wider offer that you said kind of
draws up the whole of of of mid-suffic
baber going into to North Essex and um
and South Norfolk so yeah um as we as we
move into the action plan you'll see
there's a much larger piece of work to
come on this which is all around our
itinerary offer
thank you you have a further questions
just come back and say I've just noticed
on page 28 of the report that it does
talk about
um
where are we now no tour of constable
country can ignore Christchurch Mansion
hopefully Andy then goes on to talk
about the fact that Alfred munnings
despite the munnings art gallery being
located in Essex despite it being
located in
it makes it sound as though as it is
some sort of purgatory that you should
avoid at all costs
I I can't cancel the internet I think I
think I think that that that is good but
I think it needs to be pulled out into
much more Punchy bits and pieces so this
is rather hidden within the the text of
the of a very lengthy and detailed
detailed report and if we can pull out
some of the of those things into a more
Punchy way then I think it would help us
enormously thank you for that that's a
helpful but um I do think that um
there has to be an understanding that
this is available mid-suffer strategy
and and we do recognize through the
comments that you have made
um that we do need to involve as
Christchurch mentioned which is a Nitric
Borough and and minings which again is
is a conscious Navara so um these are
it's a recognition that they are outside
of our boundaries but but we're not
ignoring them and we're not um uh and
this is where the the whole point
between collaboration with with other
authorities comes comes in because
there's recognition that close by
um are these
these places which show importance to
what we're trying to achieve with our
strategy here
we'll now move into uh debate I've got
Castle hospital and then Council on lvc
and then councilor McLaren
oh a question still oh right sorry okay
yeah well
Jade
did you have a question as well yeah
Osborne well VC McLaren in that sequence
threat that there's a lack of suitable
and affordable
um hotels accommodation
um and I would have thought that was a
big threat there's somewhere I'm not
sure where I've seen it but I know that
I've seen that there's there's a real
lack of hotels in Suffolk and Essex as
well but mainly in Suffolk and I would
have thought that was a real threat
because if we've got if we want to
attract visitors we've got nowhere to
put them up I know it's particularly a
problem in Sudbury
um then obviously that's a threat isn't
it to to encouraging visitors into the
area so I thought that would have been
identified as a threat if not a threat
or weakness we have identified as as
part of the the work that the working
group went through we did talk about
this
um and I'm sure
sure is documented somewhere but it's
something that we did discuss the lack
of Hotel accommodation
Fiona can you clarify that one please so
I'm reliably informed by my colleagues
to my left that um it is in the full
insights report it just hasn't has been
missed off the summary which is uh which
is in front of you right what I would
say is um we're obviously aware of the
um I was going to say perception but I
think it's more than that the the the
growing cause for more accommodation and
that certainly has been discussed and
some of the theme workshops and one of
the actions that will come out of this
is that we'll do a more in-depth piece
of work to provide an Evidence base for
a hotel need so that that is an action
that we already know that we're going to
be doing
um and we'll be cracking on with that as
soon as soon as this gets approved
really okay thank you thanks
I'm just
I'm just called Chester
Colchester if I'm not mistaken is in
Essex
and unfortunately it does have a lot of
hotels so it can accommodate people to
which we don't in Bieber or mid-suffolk
the other thing that the first thing
that prompted me was um
I'm a firm believer in innocent until
proven guilty but unfortunately Mr John
peel has had some claims
and I do think that to include
any reference
to any individual who's got a very dark
cloud hanging over them is a bit scary
it's a bit worrying
okay um yeah
I mean you know they are only claims
but until he is cleared
I think it it sends a bad message out
and then I just wondered where where's
little long Melford with its two grade
one listed buildings
okay thank you thanks thanks
Council McLaren
I did raise the
um
subject to stories in fact when you look
at all our
Heritage sites a lot of them had stories
about people so we have constable in
gainsbury and I just wondered I spoke to
my Parish councils about this and I was
wondering are we going to harness some
of those areas like chocolate Peninsula
that needs some stories about there's
quite a few previous people have lived
on shortly and I was wondering how we're
going to harness that are we going to go
out to Parish councils or interested in
groups in areas and ask for
contributions to this strategy thank you
thanks Fiona do you want to come back on
them
below this strategy this strategy really
provides a framework and exactly what
you've described sits under theme three
which is around collaborating with
um not just Partners across borders but
but also local people local communities
and so absolutely we'll see some of that
coming out through distinct actions in
the action plan
thank you
does anyone else we should say Council
arthi
well just to say that I think councilor
malvesi may have brought up quite an
important point with regard to the John
peel Center which has a photo in here
it's a strategy that's designed to last
for the next five years I think isn't it
um and I did read over the weekend that
Glastonbury I think have renamed the
John Peale stage and the BBC have
renamed the John peel wean
um because of all of
um
stories that are coming out now you say
innocent until proven guilty but of
course he died a few years ago so I
don't quite know how they're going to
apportion
of guilt but um yeah I think I think
Council malvesi has made a good point it
may be better to refer to an Arts Center
or something rather than actually have a
picture of John Peel's name on the wall
okay
um I think we've probably made the the
point on that on
does anyone have anything else that they
wish to say about
the rest of the strategy and and um
the information that it's it provides
that there's a huge amount of work
that's gone into it as as I mentioned
earlier
um the the evidence basis is excellent
um we've got a really good
um online map of Assets Now
um the SWOT analysis leading aside the
issue of Hotel accommodation I think
it's thorough and and very helpful to to
the strategy
um and and I'm very pleased with the
overall piece of work I think that every
the fact that it's had so much input
from so many
um Parts not just members officers but
also external organizations and and
businesses in the sector I think gives
it a lot of strength and credibility and
um the action plans coming out of it I'm
sure are going to be very very helpful
and um
did you want to say something sorry yes
I was just just gonna say that um
the boat Paul's point was made about the
shotley peninsula of course because the
Ganges Mast is currently being
refurbished yep so that's obviously
something can be added into it at the
moment it's not there at the moment sort
of thing but it will be be there within
the period time frame for this
um but every single part of our district
has got various little stories which if
we go out to the parishes and ask them
we could end up with a nice little uh
yeah portfolio of ideas yeah there's
there's a massive amount you're quite
right and I know we've talked about the
artists and and I mentioned the
um the The Vineyards but it goes across
all sorts of things you write again use
Master we've got the um the World War II
Heritage around Raiden and latinum
airfields there's there's so much that's
that's um and plus all of the uh the
food sector with Jimmy's Farm the
Suffolk Food Hall
so um
for when I say small not so much a small
business a small District in population
terms a large District in in um
geographical terms um there's there's a
massive amount in paper
okay
um does anyone else wish to make any
comment about this in which case we'll
move to the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
that is six votes for that's unanimous
chair thank you well thanks everyone
that brings us to the close of today's
cabinet meeting the next meeting is
scheduled for Monday the 12th of June at
2PM
um I hope
um as many of us as possible are still
here then but we will have to uh wait to
see what the electorate has to say about
that but um
in case
in case um we're not but I would like to
thank members of the cabinet for all of
their work and their support
um I know not all of you being cabinet
members over the full past four years
but those you have it's been a long
period and and those are the of you who
are newish to the cabinet and thank you
for stepping in when I've asked you to
and and for the support and work that
you've put in I know
um councilman McLaren for instance has
really quickly got on top of her
portfolio and um I'm very pleased that
um at that and
um so it's been
fairly enjoyable four years I think
coming up haven't we yes a special
cabinet meeting on the 17th so I'll
thank you all again then
yes we've got um a one-off one yes I had
I had forgotten that anyway thanks
everyone